oh cool  why there's I got there's things things  things like things I can help out with  Oh some family things Garoppolo I  understand that anything I can us family  rusty family comes first any time it's  nice it's really good to see you yeah I  know it's good to see you so since uh I  still have you ask that number I'll give  you a call um you know bond so see ken  ken please let me put 10 live in the  engine  ten million  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  bodies you want that don't you  we're gonna have so much fun  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  see I told you we'd be playing games  together together forever  best friends forever stay toasty my  friends  [Music]